あの僕の後輩のユーチューバーで縦メンってやつがいるんですよ
結構最近仲良くさせてもらってて結構物に電力するんですけどもあの1一転ところです
ねほんとはたくさんあるデスクだよ
一点だけどうしても
にくいところがありますねこれで許すれって終わるんですけども何かと言いますと彼の
笑い方です
まあ普通の人が笑うとこんな感じだと思うんですよあっはぁこれを違う
はっはー
あーぐらいだと思うんですけどもうかはいつの悪い方がねえ強さとっぽいんですよ1回
真似してみますよ
[音楽]
あっほら今日はきやから強行
ザッパーン実物を見ないとちょっとわからないと思うねこの後日本でやってもらうん
ですけどもあいつの笑い方のウザさを皆さんにお伝えできればいいなと思っております
でぱっと見でも面白いですけども
それが毎日毎日毎日枚つまりず毎日毎日されると本当にイライラしていると思うので
是非みてくださいでは媚びよ
re ん
me
ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
うんながらられません
美味しいがいっぱいなくて来も増やせるがなぜん
前回は食レポの人すごいです作っていった
capade
おっふぅん
なぜ名曲にいるけどさぁ
前田よく知らない人も多いわけだ多いね
ちょっと食べて自己紹介マー君はいユーチューバーでしょご紹介
てのありがと
はいますから桜
できますか
やばいやばいやばいー
あっはあっやんよん
何ですかねっああわかったも飲まない方が変なまぁ楽しくいこうぜ
楽しいんだっ派
ああああああピョンん
ねぇまあまあされそういう顔なるいやいやいやーワードたんっ
さあ平壌やるー
列にのっつっ悪いと思うと度笑い方って人それぞれだから僕わー
いいと思うけどニックさっほー
[笑い]
per me
ねぇいいと思うよいいと思いますね
ザッハー
[拍手]
ブーブー
使い2俺だってやだけどねあっホンマ
こうしてもらうんだけどあの機能とか家の数行った時に譲れるの理由だ
あっはぁっ笑ってダウン杖
本当にはレミーですかいや違う違う違う違う違うは違います
あっはぁはぁピョン forever ファイアーロスぽっち本 t 本1本
はっはっはっよくスポーツ x5欠乏苦痛
マーク連続緩和策はスタッフらはしちゃうさあ
プロパーくわっ
[音楽]
ブーバーよ java いっす
やばいやばいやば友達っぽい序文山田開くですねー
すごいもんな
[笑い]
ブーバーし
ファンマナーが付
なんで済んだ何をやないだけなんだけどねうんちょっとまずいかなぁん
面白いけどね俺は前です動的に面白い youtube として面白いと思える are
you do right 思う
ダードってこれええええっ
the
[音楽]
me
うううう
ana あった